deux millions de litres de lait a
gaspillé en cinq jours et ce sont les
producteurs laitiers les grands perdants
dans cette ferme rappel stany a dû se
débarrasser de tous sont les
4200 les
la poubelle
qui
marque un bond au sol
mercredi les employés d'agropur de green
bay ont déclenché une grève générale
illimitée
leur convention collective est échue
depuis un an et la question des horaires
achoppent avec l'employeur conséquence
les producteurs laitiers se retrouvent
sans endroit où transformer le relais
afin qu'ils soient mis en vente du jour
ton année bien désolé loi allait pas
penser que l'on regarde en main pour le
fun si on sera en grève c'est parce
qu'il ya des enjeux des enjeux
importants qui vise directement les
familles des grévistes nous sommes
ouverts à trouver un règlement le plus
rapidement possible justement là pour
tenter de vraiment à limiter le
gaspillage alimentaire un gaspillage
alimentaire qui arrive au moment où tout
coûte plus cher pour le consommateur
c'est une petite fraction travailler à
la poubelle
et serré une réglementation au pays est
une mesure adoptée pour certains le
gaspillage de la la femme devrait être
illégal au canada au canada
contrairement à d'autres pays c'est
pratiquement un bien public le lait qui
versait dans les secousses et du lait
payés par les canadiens les producteurs
sont passés à table pour négocier les
conditions de travail et de cette usine
noms et par contre ils doivent supporter
le fardeau de ce conflit de travail donc
on demande aux parties prenantes de
trouver une méthode de pau pour prendre
un minimum de l'est pour éviter qu'on
certaines situations autres doivent pas
de gaspillage d'ici là les syndiqués ont
bien l'intention de tenir leur bout tant
qu'une entente ne sera pas trouvée ici
daniel kadjo radio canada montréal